All right. Welcome everyone, and uh
good afternoon.
Uh, my name is Ankur,
and uh, I'm joined by my colleague
here today, Mark Andrews,
and we're gonna be talking to you
about AI model development
with SageMaker.
So, let's dive in with the
key challenge.
These days, when I talk to customers,
they often tell me
that how easy it has become
for them to access
generative AI models and start using them.
But they also tell me that because of the same fact,
now they feel that
everybody has access to access to the same models.
In fact, their competitors have access
to the same models as I do.
So they ask me, well, how do we build differentiation?
Now we think that differentiation is
a key component of innovation,
as is creating value for customers.
But how do you create differentiation?
The models that you work with are
genetic, you know,
so we don't think that
creating differentiation will happen
through building better AI with the same commodity
foundation.
We think what
to create differentiation, what you need
is our models who deeply
understand you and your business.
But how do you get that competitive advantage?
Well, first, let's acknowledge
that the generative AI models that are out
there today,
they're amazing.
You know, they can,
uh, they can create,
write,
summarize, reason, you name it.
They're genuinely intelligent and they,
you know, hold a vast amount of information.
But They don't know
about your business, your domain.
They don't know about your data. They don't
understand the hidden patterns in
your transactional history
or your support tickets or
the domain expertise that you have
over the years.
They also don't know about your
constraints in your business.
Whether what's considered safe and compliant
in your business and what's considered
high quality.
So ultimately,
building models that can deeply understand
you is really about
boils down to how you make the model
learn what you want to learn.
So it's important to understand how a model learns.
Well, uh, it turns out,
models learn in a step by step
process. In the first stages
of modern learning, they learn the
generalized world knowledge.
Then they start learning more specialized
knowledge,
and then finally, they get better
at executing tasks.
This is actually not much different than
how models learn.
So let's actually take a look at
uh the human model, uh, the human
learning journey and how it compares
to uh how models learn.
So let's start with pre-training, which is the first
stage of model learning.
At this stage, the model
basically mimics a child who
is learning language by immersion.
It consumes a vast amount of text,
images, and other data,
and it learns how to predict the next token.
At this stage, the model is not
learning any specific tasks,
but it is the foundation that
is created at this stage that it draws
upon later during inferences,
much like how humans recall
early language skills in daily
conversations. Now, after
having mastered
basic language skills,
now the model is ready to learn
how to follow instructions.
So it is exposed to
uh pairs of input and output.
Questions with good answers,
and through that, it learns how to
stay on topic,
provide structured explanations and
be generally helpful.
This is much like middle school students
learning
how to write essays and follow directions.
Now the next stage
is preference optimization.
At this stage, the model
learns how to not just be correct, but
how to be good.
So it's exposed to ranked and
rated examples
of um of responses
that it learns from and it
understands
what humans think
is concise,
clear,
and aligned with social norms.
This is similar to how
high school students refine their
communication and tone through
feedback from teachers.
And in our model's case, the model
is learning, judgment, and empathy.
Now college
represents a shift
from memorization to reasoning.
So this is where
the model practices multi-step thought,
problem decomposition.
And
thinking through and providing structured
answers.
This is commonly done through techniques
such as reinforcement learning.
And this is quite similar to how
college students are able to synthesize
ideas across multiple disciplines.
Now after graduation.
In the workforce,
the model has to switch from
learning to doing.
At this point, the model has to apply
whatever it has learned
to real world tasks.
Now, much like many of us
professionals who like to continue taking,
uh,
you know, educational courses
while we are working,
models can still continue to learn.
Through techniques such as LA
and parameter efficient fine tuning,
models can continue to learn even when they're
out there deployed in production.
Without having to retrain the base model.
OK. So let's talk about uh
pre-training
in more detail, which is the first stage.
Of the model's learning journey.
So during pre-training, the model
is trained on a massive amount
of tokens from diverse
data sources,
and through this it learns
patterns in the data.
It learns how to predict the next token,
uh, based on a sequence of tokens,
and it also discovers grammar and
syntax and facts and it
builds internal representation.
Also,
while there are different scaling laws today,
generally speaking,
with larger models with more training
steps, more compute and more data.
Uh, models
achieve stronger generalization and capabilities.
Now, note that at the pre-training stage,
the model is not learning how to execute
a particular task or how to become an
expert in any one topic.
Well, this sounds simple, right?
But in reality,
the pre-training um
stage uh is quite complicated
to execute through.
The multiple challenges that you face
when you're pre-training a model.
The first one is efficient scaling.
Well, these models are large
and there's a lot of data being used to train
them, so they often don't fit onto
a single AI accelerator.
So you have to
uh pre-train over a large
cluster of AI accelerators such as GPUs
or AWS training instances.
And
so you need solutions to be able to efficiently
scale across a large number of
accelerators.
The next challenge you run into is resiliency.
Well, unlike uh distributed
data computing workloads where
every work is kind of doing its own thing,
in distributed training.
Every process, every training
process across all your GPUs in a cluster,
uh, is collaboratively training one model.
So whenever there is a failure
in the system,
either even a single GPU fails, the
entire training process stops.
So resiliency of your infrastructure
is extremely important.
Next comes utilization. Well, let's
face it, these AI accelerator-based
clusters are expensive.
So if they're not fully utilized,
it can lead to wastage and cost overruns.
So maintaining high utilization is
extremely important.
You also want to make sure that the engineers and data
scientists who are working on your pre-training
projects, they're able to focus
on value-added work rather
than dealing with infrastructure.
So having the right tools to ensure
that they are able to be highly productive is
important. And while
your training is running, it's also important
for you to have
a good amount of insight,
uh, insight into what's happening within your
training job and have observability
across your training staff.
And lastly,
there are new open source tools
that are
becoming available and popular
very quickly these days. So you want to make
sure that your infrastructure
gives you the ability to be able
to use new tools as
they become available.
So the composability of your AI stack is
important. Well,
before we move forward,
uh, I wanna talk to you about how
the, the overall,
the two big areas, the two big ways
you can train models on SageMaker.
The first one is SageMaker training jobs.
So this is an ephemeral
training job capability
where you submit, you, you
have your training code
and you submit a training job.
And it goes and spins up the infrastructure
to train your model, does the training, monitors
the model, and then spins down the infrastructure.
The second option is SageMaker Hyperpod.
Hyper Hyperpod provides a persistent cluster
of AI accelerators for you to train
your models.
And hyperpod automatically offers
uh handles
uh downtime failover and
also provides you full control and flexibility
in your infrastructure.
We're talking a little bit more about Hyperpod.
So, in Hyperpod,
you can
spin up a cluster of AI accelerators
quickly,
you can orchestrate your workloads
using either Qubinities
or using SLERM. Many of our customers
who have run HVC workloads before
prefer to use SLERM as a, as an interface, and
which is why we provide that choice.
In addition, Hyperpod is integrated
with uh tools such as StageMaker Tensor
support, as well as provides capabilities
for real-time scheduling and prioritization
of your training jobs.
Also, it has built in fault tolerance,
so it's able to recover
from failures
quickly, which we'll
talk a little bit more about in the
in the next few minutes.
It's also highly customizable.
So it's at the top layer, as I
mentioned, it supports different orchestration
options through
Amazon EKS as well as SLUM
for job submission,
you can use the Hyperpot CLI
or you could also directly use Cube
CTL,
Ray, um, the SLUM client
or Composer.
It's has out of the box support
for observability through integrations
with uh Prometheus, Graffaa, and CloudWatch.
In addition, it supports all popular
AI frameworks such as Pytorch, Tensorflow,
Nemo, and JAX.
And lastly, it also supports
all the latest AI accelerated
instances on AWS,
both GPUs and ranium,
and a variety of
different storage options that you can use in your pre-training
workload. Now
one challenge that we've seen is with
pre-training as we talked about resiliency earlier.
Is that
as your cluster size grows.
The frequency of failures
increases.
Because, and why, why is that relevant? It's
relevant because,
you know, as I mentioned earlier, in
distributed training,
you know, even if a single GPU fails,
your entire training process across
the cluster comes to a halt.
So, and as the cluster size grows,
the probability of a failure increases
because you have more GPUs in the cluster.
And
so as the frequency of failures increases,
you're spending more and more time in
dealing with those failures than actually making training
progress. And
why does this lead to, why is this a problem?
Because when a failure occurs,
And you have to spend time
in finding the root cause.
Then you have to spend time in taking remediation
actions such as restarting or even replacing
the failed node with a healthy node, and
then restarting the entire training cluster.
Then you have to restore from the previous checkpoints,
from durable storage,
and then restart all the training frameworks
and processes on every GPU
in the cluster.
And this process can actually take hours.
So in hyperpod,
we've created a self-healing.
Capability to handle such faults. So when your
training is running and a node fails, Hyperpod
automatically detects and diagnoses the
issue. If a node needs to be replaced,
then it, it does that automatically, and
then it automatically restores your
training from the last safe checkpoint,
and then it automatically resumes training.
But there's still a key challenge.
The first one is that there is an all
or nothing cascade problem here.
When the training is stopping
because of a of a fault, then it's
stopping on all GPUs on your cluster.
Your cluster is completely stopped. It's not doing any
work, so that leads to a lot of wastage.
2, all the recovery steps
are sequential.
First, you're replacing a failed
node with a healthy node.
Then you are,
uh, you know, restoring, uh,
uh, from the last safe checkpoint and then
you're restarting all the training processes.
All of that is sequential in nature and blocks
the,
every step of the way.
The second thing is
the checkpoint-based recovery is expensive
because you're loading the checkpoints from persistent
storage onto compute nodes.
And that can take
tens of minutes based on the size
of your checkpoint.
And at scale,
this has a big impact because overall
recovery from faults can take
up to an hour.
So, yesterday in the keynote,
uh, we announced
checkpointless training on hyperpod.
So this capability completely changes
the paradigm for distributed training at scale.
The way it works is
when a failure occurs during
a distributed training job.
Uh, checkpointless training
is able to
not rather than stopping all
the training processes, it keeps the
training processes alive and it's
able to restore
model state
through a peer to peer mechanism from nearby
nodes that have model state.
And that way it's able to recover
from failures without having to restart
any infrastructure or training processes
or and without relying on
any checkpoint in durable storage.
So essentially you get a restart
list and a checkpoint list system.
And
with that, what that means is that you're able to
recover from faults in mere seconds.
So Let's
take an example of how this works.
When a failure occurs in a traditional checkpoint-based
recovery,
you're diagnosing and triggering a recovery,
and then you're reinitializing your cluster.
And that happens on all GPUs in the cluster.
And then you're downloading your checkpoint
from S3.
And finally, you're also then resuming
training. So there's
a big difference between
the steps that a traditional process follows
and how quickly checkpointless training
is able to
recover from the fault.
Now, all the latest NA models
that we announced this week
were all trained using this capability,
and what we found
uh in those during
those training, um,
training projects was that, uh,
using this capability we were able to recover
from faults in many cases in seconds
and at larger scale
within 1 to 2 minutes.
And it also helped us achieve
consistently achieve 95%
good on our training cluster.
So, checkpointless training
under the hood is underpinned by
important innovations.
The first one is optimize collective communication
initialization.
So when a distributor training job
is initializing, it has to establish
uh communication channels. Every
node has to do that.
And traditionally the way it happens is, is
that there's a central root server that
coordinates
establishing all, all those communication
channels,
and that creates a big bottleneck.
So with this capability we've
gotten rid of that
centralized root server and we've
developed a new peer to peer mechanism
of nodes to discover
each other and establish communication channels.
So that reduces the
communication initialization from minutes
to seconds.
The second is
memory map data loading.
So when you're resuming training,
You need your training process needs
access to training data,
and many times you have
data pipelines that require pre-processing
and it can take
several minutes
for you to pre-process that data and actually
make it available to your training process.
So this new innovation
caches the training data in shared
memory
through memory mapped files that persist
across training failures. So when your training resumes,
it has instant access to training data
while your data pipeline is initializing.
The 3rd is in process recovery.
This means that
when a failure occurs.
This capability
does not have to stop the training processes,
it keeps the training processes running,
and then,
uh, so your training basically just
pauses and resumes.
And last is checkpointless recovery
where. Hyperpod
is able to swap failed components
with healthy ones through a peer to peer
recovery of model and optimizer
state from healthy AI accelerators
rather than relying on an explicit
checkpoint.
Now let's talk about another
problem or challenge we face in
during pre-training, which is of infrastructure
underutilization.
Now, uh
Idle compute
happens to be a key challenge here because if
your jobs, the way your jobs
are running, if they are not,
uh, if they're not utilizing your infrastructure
fully, then it leads to compute
being wasted and that leads to cost overruns.
It also leads to suboptimal prioritization.
Because if you have high priority
jobs run uh waiting in the queue
because your low priority jobs are running,
then obviously you're not
working on the most important things.
This wastage also increases your cost
and reduces productivity for
your developers because oftentimes they're
waiting for infrastructure availability
rather than
being able to make progress.
So we've solved this
in StageMaker
through uh uh hyperpo task
governance,
which automatically runs your jobs according
to their priority.
And you can also adjust these priorities
in real time.
It also offers you real-time observability.
So you can monitor your overall cluster
utilization.
Both at the cluster level as
well as at job and and team level.
This helps you reduce idle compute.
And minimize task wait time.
And it helps you
increase and maximize your overall compute
utilization in your cluster.
So the way it works is
With this capability, you can go into hyperpod
and you can set up different types of
tasks, such as training, fine tuning,
experimentation, or even infants,
and you can give them weights.
Then you can set up compute allocations.
You can define your teams or projects.
And allocate compute limits to them.
And finally, you can also specify
how idle compute is allocated
whenever there is free compute capacity
available within the cluster,
you can control whether it
becomes it's distributed to different
teams of projects or jobs in a first
come first serve basis or using a fair
fair share way which uses the weights
that you define for different tasks to allocate
capacity.
In addition, you can set up lend
and borrow rules. So there, here you
can define whether a team
can automatically borrow compute
capacity from another team when it
is available,
or can a team lend its compute
capacity to another team when it's available,
and all of this happens automatically.
You can also control
whether higher priority tasks can
preempt lower priority tasks.
So you're always working on the most important
things. So
let's talk about another challenge related to infrastructure
underutilization during pre-training.
Now, distributed training jobs
are quite inflexible.
What I mean is that once you've started the
job with a set of nodes, let's
say you're running a job with 8 nodes,
then until your job has completed.
You have to continue with the same node
configuration.
But oftentimes the compute availability
changes. Sometimes more compute may
become available and you may want to use it in your
existing training job to make it go faster.
Or other times
there might be another high priority job that may
need some compute,
and you may want to take some compute out
of the training job that you're running to make
that job go faster.
However,
today, if you need to do that, you need to completely
stop the training
workload that you're running, need to completely
reconfigure it.
With the new uh node configuration
and then completely restart and rerun it. So
that obviously leads to
a lot of wastage and um
and, and, and delay.
So to solve this yesterday we also
announced elastic training on
hyperpod.
What this does is,
when your training job is running.
It helps you define uh
scaling rules for your training job,
and when
you need, uh, when there is
extra capacity available,
it helps your training job automatically scale
up, and when you need more
capacity out of this training job, it can also scale
down and give you capacity back while continuing
to execute.
This is also done in a way that does
not impact model convergence
because it shrinks and grows in terms
of data parallel replicas.
So let's see how it works. So
you've got a training job running.
You have 4 nodes become available and
so your training job automatically scales up
and then further scales up.
And then,
when you need capacity
out of this training job, because let's say your
infants is scaling up and you need capacity
to scale infants up,
it can also easily scale down
and uh and the training
continues to make progress throughout this process.
Let's talk about another key challenge
of observability.
So, uh,
you know,
when you're running your training,
uh, training job, it's very important for
you to have a very deep understanding
of what's going on in your cluster,
right? So, I'll tell you,
I'll give you one example. So,
um, some time ago, before this capability
existed,
our science team at AWS they were working
on, uh, some training projects.
And they saw a dip
in the model training performance.
And they were wondering why that's happening,
and it took us days to figure out that
that was happening because of certain
temperature fluctuations at the GPU level.
Right? And there wasn't good tooling
to actually root cause that quickly.
Your training stack is like a layered cake. It
has so many different layers from your training code
to, you know, your training
frameworks to compute,
networking and the actual hardware.
So, it's very important that you have,
um, you know, high quality observability
in your training solution.
So that's why we build hyperpod observability.
This gives you one click and out
of the box support for Amazon
managed Prometheus and Gfana.
Uh, it offers preconfigured metrics
across all layers of the stack from your
job level metrics to
compute layer to our networking layer
and hardware.
And also this scales automatically
with Azure cluster scales.
OK. So we've talked about
how our model
learns more general information through
pre-training.
Let's not talk about post-training or model customization.
Because that's where we create real value and
real differentiation.
So at a high level,
There are
many different fine tuning or model customization
techniques available today.
Let's talk about each of them and see where they
are relevant.
So the first one
is supervised fine tuning.
So with supervised fine tuning, the
model directly learns from labeled
input output data.
And it can use this to improve
overall task performance and
understand your domain.
And this is actually quite
useful when you have a have
clear ground truth available with you.
So, commonly used,
common use cases for fine tuning
include customer support Q&As and
summarization tasks where you have
gold standard references
or even domain adaptation when you
need to adapt your
model to, let's say jargon
from me or terms from
medical field or legal or finance.
Next, let's talk about reinforcement
learning. Reinforcement
learning is interesting.
The way it works is.
The model generates multiple outputs
and then it reserve and it receives
a reward or a penalty,
and based on that it knows whether,
you know, what to do and what not to do.
And so it's extremely
useful
for long form reasoning and adherence
to multi-rule policies.
Now, The way RL
works is
there's a
policy model in the system, in the RL
system, which is basically the model that you're
fine tuning.
It generates rollouts, which is basically
different outputs for a given prompt.
Then, uh, a component
computes rewards using a reward function
or a model,
and then an optimization algorithm
updates the model
based on those rewards.
And there are a few different variations
of this.
When the reward
is computed based on labeled
human data.
This is known as
RLHF or RL from human feedback.
When an AI judge or AI model
acts as a judge and computes these rewards,
then it is known as RL from
AI feedback, and this is quite useful
when there's a large
amount of reward computation that needs to
happen and you don't have enough
uh human resources to label that
data. And lastly,
For cases where you can programmatically
verify the accuracy
of model output, you can
also write a reward function.
To do RL and this is known as RL
from verifiable rewards.
And this is easy because it's, uh, you know,
it's, it's, it's scalable
and it's, it has, it doesn't, it's objective,
it has less bias
and it's for specific tasks such as,
um, you know,
coding and uh tasks with
clear correctness signals. This is quite
a popular technique.
And the last one
is direct preference optimization.
So, DPO is a close cousin of
RL but not quite RL?
In the sense that
with DPO you're telling the model,
you show the model that hey,
I prefer this response for a given
prompt I prefer this response
over the other and through that the model
learns your preferences
and so this technique is quite useful
for subjective or style driven
learning. So let's say you want to make your model
learn about,
uh, you know, um, learn your brand
voice or or values or
how um the tone.
Uh, that you want in your chatbot.
And it's also easy to implement
because it doesn't
require um the full RL
setup. Well,
but here's the reality,
like, these techniques are great,
but then to implement them, I actually
put them to use.
You know, you have to wrestle with a lot of different
things. First,
you have to deal with a lot of infrastructure
set up because there are different components
involved from,
you know, uh
accumulating data to running
these different techniques, and the setup
for all these different techniques is actually
quite different.
And then you have to evaluate models and then
if you're doing this at this at enterprise
scale, then you also have to worry about
governance and who has access to what
and whether you have full lineage
tracking in place.
So all in all you're spending more time
plumbing than actually doing value added work.
So this is
where SageMaker comes in. So SageMaker
acts as
a unified runway
for a model customization.
First, it offers a broad choice
of models that you can customize out of the box,
including the Amazon Nova models and
other open weights models such as GPT
OSS,
Lama models, Queen,
Deep Seek, and more.
And it supports
all the popular
different fine tuning techniques from reinforcement
learning to supervised fine tuning and
direct preference optimization.
And the entire process for
model customization in StageMaker is
fully managed.
And so you don't have to deal with any
infrastructure uh management.
So yesterday, we also announced
serverless training jobs
on SageMaker, which can help you customize
these models
without having to deal
with any compute capacity.
It's very simple, you basically
pick your data and pick the model that you
wanna customize,
and you can either use an API
or the UI
to kick off a completely serverless training
job. Now,
once you've customized your model, you
also want to make sure that it's actually
better than the model that you started with.
Now, to do that, evaluation of
the model that you've customized is
extremely important.
So for that
we've also launched a new model
evaluation capability.
Again, this is available both through the
API as well as our UI, which
is Sage Maker Studio.
And it supports multiple modes of evaluation
from, uh,
you can evaluate a model using standard
industry benchmarks or you can use
an LLM as a judge
to which can uh where an AI model
acts as a critic for
the. Model you're evaluating,
and you can also define your own custom metrics
for evaluation.
And then when you're running your training, you also
want to make sure that you're able to capture
and look at different metrics
such as training loss or your reward
uh metrics
and um
ML flow has emerged as a popular
tool
for doing such experiment tracking.
And looking at different metrics.
So, uh, this week we also announced
a serverless ML flow
in SageMaker,
and so you can use serverless ML
flow to start logging
metrics from your training experiments
and, and review them easily.
Um, and also when you customize a model
using our serverless training jobs in SageMaker
now, your uh your metrics
from your training job automatically show up in
ML flow.
OK, so we talked about the tools and techniques,
but how do you use them,
right? Well, there are 3 ways.
In Sagemaker.
One is the code-based path where you
have access to an SDK to easily
customize a model.
The second is a UI path
where you can use an easy to use UI
in a point and click fashion to customize
a model in twin.
And the third one is an agent
guided path.
So this is where an agent can
work with you and collaborate with you
to design a customization task and
actually execute on it.
So, this is an example of the,
of the code base path. So,
using the SageMaker AI SDK
you can start customizing
uh models uh in a few minutes, in
a, in a few lines of code.
Also, you can write these codes in whatever
ID you want, but you can also
use
built-in Jupiter Lab and open source
VS code um IDEs
within SageMaker.
And also you can start with
code and then jump to UI
or vice versa.
So next is the UI guided fine
tuning.
So, uh,
The way this works is
That you can go to models,
you can select a model and say you want to customize
with UI.
And let's say you give it a name,
select your fine tuning technique. In this
case, we are using RLVR.
And then
you can select a reward function that
you previously created.
You select your data
And then you can simply just submit
the training job
and off it goes and executes.
Now, once your training job is running,
you can
monitor its performance.
And once the model is done,
you can also evaluate.
The model.
Uh, you can create a new evaluation job. You can
select, uh, let's say in this case, if you're selecting
an LLM as a judge approach,
you can select the, uh, the, the judge model.
You can also select the metrics that you
want to evaluate the model on.
You can also provide your own custom data sets
and prompts for evaluation.
And then when you kick off the evaluation job, it's
completely serverless
and uh it just executes
in the background.
Now going back to the custom
model that we've created here.
You can monitor different metrics as the job is
running. You
can also go back to your evaluation job
and look at different evaluation steps and
their progress.
And then once the evaluation is, uh,
job has completed,
you can look at
evaluation results.
On the UI or you can also download
the results via 3.
In addition,
When you've evaluated the job and now you want to
deploy it, you can easily just click the deploy
button. And deployed
either on a SageMaker infants endpoint
or um imported into bedrock.
So here,
we're choosing a StageMaker endpoint
to deploy this model to.
So in this case, right now it's deploying,
now it's done,
and you can, once the model is deployed, you can
open the playground
and you can actually start chatting with the model
to test
the output.
Here we're just going to put some sample text.
And see that the model actually responds,
which is great.
Now we can.
Go back to our model page.
And in addition
to the metrics,
what we also have
um is other information
um such as a lineage.
So with the our lineage tool, you can see
all the changes that the model has gone through,
what data was used, what job was
run, what approvals were used to run
those jobs,
and what evaluations were done, etc.
You can also see all the training logs, and
this is available as the training job is executing.
All right.
So now let's move uh
and move to the agent guided
path and see how that works.
So again, you can choose
the option to customize a model with an
AI agent.
You can give your conversation a name.
And then you can
In simple language, you can describe your use
case. And then the agent
asks you questions to clarify your use case.
It asks you to select a
base model.
And then it generates a use case specification,
which describes the use case
and success tenets, which will
later be used to evaluate the model.
Finally, it also generates some,
based on your use case, it also generates some data
examples which you can edit or
uh or uh improve.
And then it generates a data generation specification,
which determines how
your data
for this model customization will be generated.
It also then goes ahead and generates
synthetic data for you,
uh, using the examples or using
uh contextual data that you provide.
And once that's done,
you can look at.
The samples of the synthetic data generated
and you can also get data quality
metrics such as data diversity and
other statistics as well as responsible AI metrics.
Once that's done,
Because we're, the, the agent recommended
RLVR,
uh, it also gives you a starting,
uh, reward function template based
on your use case which you can further edit
and, and approve.
Once you've done that, now you're ready to
kick off your training job.
You can start
the job
just by talking to the agent and then you can
also review
and monitor the training progress
within the same screen.
Once your training is done,
you can also review the evaluation
criteria in tenets and make any revisions
to it. Once you approve it,
the agent goes and runs the evaluation.
Once that's done,
you can easily see
the evaluation results.
So here you see that the fine-tuned
model actually performed much better
than the base model on a number of different metrics.
And after that, you can also go and
deploy the model,
um, from the models page to StageMaker
or Bedrock.
So to summarize, there are 3 important pillars
when it comes to model development on Sagemaker AI.
The first is of choice,
and we use this as a core design tenet in
all our capabilities.
Where we offer choice of different models that
you can use and customize,
choice of different customization techniques,
and also choice of different interfaces from
UI to SDK2 agent.
We also focus on efficiency,
so with the new server-less experience, you don't
have to worry about infrastructure management,
and it reduces the time for
customizing your models from months to days.
When you're doing AI at scale,
doing it safely and securely is,
uh, is really important.
So with built-in
governance and lineage capabilities,
you don't have to worry about,
you know, how your models are being
used and who has access to what, and
you have full visibility into the changes
that have gone into the model. Plus also you can
securely, you know,
control access with IM
and run these jobs in your VPC.
All right. So now, let's move on to
talk about how you can build with Amazon
Nova on StageMaker, and for that, I'll call upon
my colleague Mark Andrews.
Awesome. Thank you, Ankar.
Alright, hey folks,
um, hopefully, or you may have seen the
announcement on Tuesday about Amazon
Nova, and we had a talk yesterday, uh, 33:25
if I'm remembering, uh, correctly,
um, so we're excited to go into this in
a little detail here again too.
This is a bit of a refresh if any of you were in that session
yesterday, but, uh, we'll blast through it. There is
a little bit of new content.
OK, so roughly.
Um,
you all operate in an environment
where you have lots of intellectual property,
your own proprietary data, which is unique
to your company. So this is the whole concept
of Nova Forge. Essentially we're
allowing you to bridge this gap here between
foundation model knowledge on the left
and organizational knowledge, which is
essentially central to your company. So
we want to
essentially bridge that divide through the
program we're calling NovaForge.
Just to kind of recap, like,
uh, to help you kind of level set on, you know, why is
Forge useful, um,
there are many different techniques you can use from,
uh, on the top left here. This is like the rag-based
approach where you're essentially bringing
knowledge context from an external source into the
model. Um, on the top right,
we have adaptations,
which is
Laura-based fine tuning is the example here where
you're you're essentially enhancing, you
know, the foundation model a small bit
in, in various dimensions.
On the bottom left we have expansion. This is
essentially where CPT with open weights
models might come in, but as you can see from the graphic
here, the risk there is it catastrophically
forgets
basic things that the model needs to be
pretty proficient in like instruction following.
And then on the bottom right hand side,
building your own model from scratch. However, building
your own model from scratch is enormously expensive
and time consuming.
So that's why we are excited to
announce Nova Forge.
This bridges that gap. It essentially
allows you to accelerate building your own foundation
model, leveraging all of the benefits
of the Sagemaker platform that Ankara
went into. Sagemaker is the
best infrastructure platform in the world to
build your own foundation model, and that's why NovaForge
is built on top of it.
So just as a quick recap, like, uh,
on Tuesday,
Matt Garman basically announced the
newer generation models, so the second generation
models that are here on the slide, that's Nova 2 Lite,
um, and on the bottom,
we have the early access models, Nova 2 Pro
and uh Nova 2 Omni.
Um, as you, if you have
seen it, you, you will also see that the
performance of these models on the, uh, third
party validated benchmarks
are very equivalent to
the leading models from, um,
uh, all of the other leading model providers.
So if you start with Nova Forge,
especially our Nova 2 family, you're starting from a
great baseline. OK,
so roughly Ankara went into this in detail, so
I'll breeze through some of this,
essentially.
You start with an empty model. Um,
this is where this is ultimately giving
you a precursor with respect to how you, how you build
this, uh, how you build a model from scratch.
Uh, you start with the scaffolding, essentially the
foundation model scaffolding.
The base model is built by through the pre-training,
um, uh, which Anchor explained
earlier, and then mid-training where you kind of refine
the context. Uh,
Think of it like a,
a pre-training being like the Grey's
Anatomy medical text,
and mid-training might be, I want to specialize in dermatology.
And then on the right hand side is your fully fine-tuned
model where you might er tweak like various
clinical practices and so on, based on your business.
These are, this, this is kind of the same thing again.
It's essentially taking your um er
on on on the previous slide, taking your,
uh, if we could go back.
Uh, it's, it's taking your long form context,
text, essentially like the Gray's, uh, medical
anatomy, uh,
anatomy, um, plus, um,
the second is, uh, you know, your focus into,
uh, dermatology, and the third is,
uh,
uh, post-training like fine tuning, and as anchor
also explained.
You have SFT and RL. Like SFT.
One example I like to think of just to keep it simple is like
dog training, right? SFT is like your obedience
school training. There's this is teaching the dog the basic
concepts like sit, uh, roll,
um, er, etc.
Um, RL is essentially you take the dog to the park.
Now there's lots of different distractions. There's a,
um, maybe you want to teach the dog new techniques.
This is where you essentially provide reward functions,
like in this case, if the dog does something good, you give it a treat.
If it doesn't do something that you want, you
say no. Um,
and essentially ultimately the end result is you
have a very aligned post-trained
model that behaves exactly how you want it to behave.
So building with Nova Forge,
the exciting part here, there are
5 key things that we've done here, um,
access to model checkpoints across all phases
of model development. I'll show that briefly on the
second slide after this.
Um, the ability to blend your proprietary
data with Amazon Nova curated training data.
Um, uh, performing reinforcement
learning with reward functions in your environment. This
is actually a key one which we will also go through,
um, using push button recipes. So this is
accelerating the modeled development cycle
itself and then using our responsible,
uh, AI toolkit if you wish.
Um, as we announced, uh,
yesterday, uh, Reddit was a key development partner
for us, and they built.
One of the world's leading moderation solutions
using NovaForge. Um, they couldn't do this with
any other model off the shelf. They used NovaForge
because it gave them the flexibility to create the
most, um, uh,
highly accurate profision model for their use case.
So building a model with Forge, essentially
this is exactly as we described earlier.
You have large volumes of unstructured
data. This is like the Grey's Anatomy text
example in the in the pre-training.
You have your specialist domain knowledge like the uh
uh dermatology in
your mid-training and then you have um instruction
following um to essentially have a
highly performant uh
uh post-train model. So in
looking at this, like the reason why
we we see a lot of advantage
to your businesses being able to
bring in your intellectual property, your i.e.
your, your, your assets in terms of what your company
is proficient in
is.
Most of the learning model, i.e., most
of the, again using the brain analogy from
earlier, neuroplasticity is highest
earlier in the process. This is where
much more data is coming into it. I think Matt
Garman used on Tuesday the analogy of a
of of a child learning a new language.
It's much easier for a child to learn a new language than
it is for an adult to use a new language.
Um, and as a result, like,
uh, before we get to the post-training phase,
there's much more neuroplasticity earlier
in the process of training,
which is why we believe
bringing your data in at that point is actually
much more proficient, i.e., it imbues
the model with the competence of your,
uh,
of your domain, uh, data.
And then post-training is still a very useful function.
This is where you refine the model and tweak it for
your specific, uh, uh, performance reasons.
So one of the key points here is
I mentioned earlier, catastrophic forgetting
is a big risk with respect to open
weights models.
The way we've helped prevent that
is through our proprietary
data mixing technique which
essentially allows you to blend
your proprietary data with Amazon's
Amazon Nova curated data.
And we'll, we'll, we'll show a slide in
a moment where it it essentially indicates
that you can blend across different domains
like math,
science, etc. etc.
um, and you can dial up or dial
down the data that you
want to reinforce or wanted to forget.
Um, but the important part is this data mixing
is actually critical to
helping prevent catastrophic forgetting. Like without
it, what can easily happen is if you bring in
too much data, the model will,
as I said earlier, basically forget very fundamental
tasks with respect to instruction following and
others. And
uh you know this is not just a hypothetical,
just take an example of um
Amazon
stores,
they improved their shopping
MMLU, the massive multi-site language
understanding, by 9.8% and
and indeed actually it improved by
2.7% on standard MMLU
tasks.
So building our model at NovaForge, there
are Uh, two
things here that, uh, that are worth mentioning,
um, with respect to reinforcement learning, you can,
um, essentially bring your reward functions into
the AWS environment yourself, but the,
the key interesting part here is that you can actually,
uh, incorporate your own reward functions
in your very own environment,
um, essentially, but, uh, through an API
that we provide.
This gives you much more flexibility to,
you know, within your own applications, essentially send
the signals back into um
the forge development environment and into SageMaker
um to reinforce the model
um live and then you can
essentially iterate as much as you want
with respect to how often you want that reinforcement
learning data to be incorporated into the core model.
And again, like, uh, you know, we've been working very
closely with key partners here, so cosign Cosign
AI, um, uh, essentially we
worked with them to develop this, uh,
API reinforcement learning solution. This
was one big thing that we, we, we learned from them
that, um, it wasn't
enough just simply to uh
incorporate their reinforcement learning data
into uh NovaForge to the
AWS environment. They wanted an API to
be able to uh have it, um,
basically push that data in real time.
Just talking briefly about Reddit, which I mentioned
as well, um,
they had amazing results with
their moderation solution. They saw a 26
point precision lift, which is
huge in, in the,
in the moderation use case.
Like they've been a key development partner here
again, like, like very, very successful results
from uh from Reddit using NovaForge.
So building your model with Nova Forge, like, uh, there
are two things here that are worth pointing out.
Um, we do provide push button recipes
so that it's easiest,
it's as easy as possible and fast as possible
for you to actually get started,
and then you have the maximum flexibility
to tweak and adjust as appropriate.
The other thing, you can do it all through the CLI, which
is on the left,
or you can use our UI which is on the right. The
other thing is you can actually interface
between the two. So if you want to start with the
UI and go to the CLI,
you can. You can also go back to the UI if you start with
the CLI later too, so they're they're, they're
fully reinforcing one another. So that gives you maximum
flexibility to. Be able to speed up or slow down
or leverage the more bin
pack techniques as appropriate and then actually on the
right hand side of the UI you can
see this is our data mixing UI so you can
see like for entertainment, you can dial it up to 5%
or whatever for factual you can have it at a higher
percentage for legal, you can turn it off if you wish,
etc. and that's a pretty long
list of
data mixing categories that you can actually dial
up or down, dial down as appropriate.
The other thing we have, uh, again, you can monitor,
of course, the er the training process
itself, and again this is reinforced by the
StageMaker platform.
So you have the full
um status of your
training jobs as they're running through the process
end to end.
So building with Nova Forge.
The main thing here is this is built on the same code
used to train Nova,
so essentially you're you're you're building on a very
powerful foundation model
as it stands.
The training code that is used if you
bring in your intellectual property is
essentially reinforcing
your domain knowledge into
the Nova model itself and then we're actually
kind of calling these novellas
um in terms of uh the uh unique models
that you may develop as as companies based
on your data.
And it's uh it is actually very important
important to point out that
these models that you develop are your models exclusively.
We do not have access to them,
no one else has access to them. It's completely your flexibility
to do with them as you wish.
You
You can, um, if you wish,
obviously, you know, if you have customers,
if you're an ISV or whatnot, actually expose
those to ISVs and allow them to further fine tune
and so on. So you know there is maximum
flexibility in what you do with the model,
but Amazon does not have access to the model
itself. It's completely within your control.
The data is also yours. We do not see the data
that goes into the model training itself.
That is yours intellectual property and that
is protected for you.
So as I mentioned before, uh, one of the other
component parts that you can leverage
if you wish is the customizable content moderation
settings, um,
you know, as I mentioned in the Reddit example, they essentially
are a,
um, uh,
a moderation platform, or, or at least
the model they developed is a moderation
solution. So
they want to dial down all of these
controls because essentially they're building that capability
from scratch.
Another example, just a simple example, is if you're law
enforcement, you know, you don't want RAI
controls to be on because that's the whole point of
what you're doing. You're trying to get the model to process,
you know, potentially disturbing
subject matter and whatnot, and that's actually part of the
solution that you may want to build.
So you have complete flexibility to turn this up,
uh, to turn this on or off, and dial it
up and down as appropriate.
The other thing that's worth pointing out, um, if you
wish to, uh,
you know, some assistance or whatnot to be able
to help identify the right data
and whatnot that you may want to incorporate
into building your own model,
uh, the AWS Gen AI Innovation
Center is there for you. Essentially this
allows you to, you know, work with them in
a professional services context to
integrate your business DNA into
your own customized model.
So, I think uh just from there,
very excited to talk about Nova Forage.
Again, we couldn't do without the er the benefit
of the SageMaker platform. So
thank you all for listening and if you have any questions,
we're happy to take them afterwards.
Thank you.